let's take some phone calls 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 is the number let's get right on
the phone see what people are thinking
we'll go to our first caller from the
309 area code caller what's your name
and where are you calling from hi I'm
Austin I'm from Chicago great what's on
your mind
yeah my question was just a pretty broad
prediction which Trump's reading of
frequent disinformation like the you
know the the three to five million
people voting for Hillary Clinton which
clearly didn't happen it had no basis
whatsoever with you know the murder rate
being the highest it's ever been in 47
years things like that and with you know
his travel ban being based on basically
nothing whatsoever and him appealing to
the nativism of its base do you think
several months along the line he'll a
Pietschmann will be possible even with
the Republican majority and basically
both chambers of Congress and the
Supreme Court yeah a lot of people have
been asking me versions of this question
I mean you have to remember lying is not
a high crime or misdemeanor or whatever
the language is for impeachment so I
think it's insane that Donald Trump and
his administration are lying to the
extent that you've you've accurately
pointed out that they are the
impeachment thing is going to be tough I
actually see if Donald Trump is not
going to complete his first term I see a
resignation a sort of negotiated
resignation which puts Mike Pence in
charge of the puts Mike Pence in the
White House is more likely than actual
impeachment and I think you're getting
at part of the reason why which is well
two of the reasons why number one when
you've got Republicans controlling every
aspect of government who unless you have
a really low approval rating for Trump
probably in the 20s before Republicans
are willing to jump on the impeachment
thing who is going to be the person to
sign their name to say I'm starting this
officially and number two as deplorable
the lying is the constant lying it's not
really an impeachable offense unless he
starts lying you know under under some
kind of oath the way Bill Clinton did
about what's the definition of is type
of thing so I think a resignations more
likely than an impeachment if anything
right of course I I mean definitely that
and I mean you know and technically you
know raiding Yemen based on an insult of
your masculinity isn't illegal either
but that's also pretty ridiculous it's
pretty ridiculous yeah thank you so much
for the call really appreciate it
important topic that we'll be watching
very very closely